When I was your age,
I'd already decided to become an artist.
I loved painting.
So much that I couldn't sleep.
Then one day, for no reason,
I couldn't paint.
I kept painting, but it was no good.
I realized that I was just
imitating other painters.
Just copies of paintings I'd seen.
I swore I'd paint my own pictures.
That must've been hard.
But after that...
it's not much easier now.
I think I found what painting means,
at least for me.
To fly, you don't chant
a spell or something, right?
We fly with our spirit.
A witch's spirit? Perfect!
That's what I'm talking about.
A witch's spirit. An artist's spirit.
A baker's spirit!
I suppose it must be a power given by God.
Sometimes, you suffer for it.
I guess I never gave witchcraft
much thought.
That talk about discipline and training
was so old-fashioned.
I was so happy that you came
all that way to see me.
Left alone, I would've been
one giant ball of frustration.
There have been many times I've thought
of painting over that painting.
Why? It's so beautiful.
When I saw you today,
I saw your sad face
and thought, "I've found it!"
-I knew I could paint you.
-Not fair!
Sure it is.
-Let's go to sleep.
-Okay.